Aaron from what you observed with some
of the other producers with these web
series that were very successful that
you came on board with how do they get
sponsorship you know that's the dream of
so many people right now is to just do a
web series put it on YouTube find
sponsorship and it sounds great in
theory how easy is it and what are the
steps I mean it's it's definitely not
easy the and the funny thing is I got my
sort of YouTube education in in this
last year to have before I shot Synod
House I started working with a company
that was producing a show called 49ers
which Jamie widows who directs Two and a
Half Men directs and it is sponsored by
subway and the the show was set up I
believe it was Jamie widows was attached
and he then went and they were pitching
networks and companies and they ended up
getting ahold of Subway which has a
massive marketing budget and pitched
them the idea that they would create a
show based on people that worked at
Subway and that's why it's the 49ers it
was the people who worked from 4 o'clock
to 9 o'clock at Subway and so part of
the show is them literally behind the
counter making sandwiches and then they
go home and you see what their home life
is like and and all that and the shows
on Hulu it's we're about to shoot the
fourth season it's done incredibly well
and Subway's very satisfied with not
only the audience that they're they've
been able to reach through the show but
also with being involved with the
finished product I mean it's the way
things used to be back in the day it
used to be like the Lucille Ball show
brought to you by some soap company
right so in watching that and then
subway was so happy with that that they
gave us this other show called summer
with summer alleys where we brought
these six singing sisters who created a
youtube sensation by doing covers of
songs on their own channel and clearly
they were the they were able to deliver
an audience of you know young girls and
you know young teens and subway was
having a hard time reaching those people
so
they turned around and went right after
that Cimorelli show created the summer
with some rallies and the show was
averaging over a million views per
episode was used everywhere and we're
doing another season of it and so I
think if you're looking for a sponsor
and this was the theory that I used for
synodos
was you want to pick something that is
going to solve somebody's marketing
problem and and I feel like Cinna Doubs
is is breaching there is approaching
this this issue of how are you gonna
market how our company is gonna compete
in this new economy there's new cannabis
economy that's that's blowing up in the
United States how our company is going
to market how are they going to compete
well it's it's a simple answer it's just
like it always was their sponsor shows
they take out ads and with YouTube and
working online it allows the creators to
work directly with the sponsors it cuts
out the middleman because you can you
know we don't need a network anymore you
know YouTube has provided that you can
start your own website if you want to so
with all of that freedom and you know
with the sponsors if they think it's
worthwhile to work with you with all of
that freedom it definitely is it's a
great exciting you know atmosphere for
creator for people you know who have
independent ideas and and just aren't
you know aren't going to wait for the
the traditional media gatekeepers to
tell you whether or not you can do your
product we just go straight straight to
the market now that brings up the other
issue that with that comes the problem
of marketing you know getting the
eyeballs to your show and that's that's
one of the big one of the biggest
challenges - well I wanted to go back so
let's suppose I have a web series about
cats okay I'm a huge cat lover so what
would I do
let's suppose I've already shot five
episodes what would you say I should do
to find sponsors for
you like what I approach Fancy Feast
what and what would be yeah what would
by my approach be and what I do this by
email would I call them I mean what did
you see work because I'm sure they're
bombarded these days oh sorry we only
have a limited budget first you know
what would be some tips that if I have
this cat web series that I can reach out
to people well I think it's you know
it's pretty much internet stalking phone
calls
going I mean and and I you know I can't
really sit here and tell you what 100%
works because it's you know I feel like
there's so many different ways to do
this sure you know one of the things
that can be frustrating with with trying
to develop your audience is that it
takes time and if you're going to a
sponsor and saying you know I'll give
you these numbers I'll you know I can
show you what I could what I've already
got you know those those that that that
language does make sense you know on
Madison area there they are starting to
realize the value of being online and
having internet channels but the problem
is is that their first targets are the
people who are the industry leaders of
course you know if you have somebody
like December airlines have two million
seven million or whatever it is is three
I think it might be three or four
million subscribers on their channel
right now so if you're able to bring
that sort of level of social media to a
sponsor that's a language they
understand if you're just starting out
you know like we are with Synod opes
ground floor no one knows where you are
you're just on a shelf in this massive
internet bookstore you know it gets a
little more difficult to walk in and say
hey I'm gonna deliver this audience
that's friendly to what you sell when
you haven't been able to show the
numbers yet or you haven't been able to
show the marketing yet I still say
you've got to get your project your
product out there you got to get your
show out there and you start to build
your fan base organically like everyone
else does you know get on the comments
start talking to your fans
try to you know you do a press release
you start contacting the you know anyone
and everyone that you can think of but
at the same time you want to be smart
about who you're targeting sponsor wise
and you know we're we're gonna be
sending one of our producers to to
Colorado next week to start looking in
Denver and see if she can meet up with
with people who are you know working in
our business I think you got to think of
it from an artistic standpoint and you
also have to think of it as a business
person so that you you know you can see
what are the opportunities that I could
give what are what are the problems I
could solve for this company and and how
would that allow me to be able to bring
my you know my ideas and my project you
know to light okay so let's suppose you
get that meeting or you get the phone
call or even if it's just an email
opportunity with a decision maker that
could give you a check but what what was
what is the pitch I'm just curious like
is it is it is it baby steps or do you
hit him with everything do you say look
this is our number this is our these are
our numbers sorry this is our synopsis
what do you remember from from working
on like 49ers and different things like
that how they went about it yeah I mean
that's the promise they were already up
fully doing
yeah I did the third season so they had
already done all that but I did you know
I did
I saw them greenlight some rallies and I
did their first season for me it was I
mean they they reacted to the results
when they started to see that they were
reaching those numbers that they were
getting you know extra views and and
their number one thing I think that that
sort of swayed it was that there was
anyone who watched the show had a
positive view of the brand after they
finished sort of to a tee and it was
done in a way that and the way those
scripts are written they're done in a
way that they're not beating you over
the head with like you know the hey by
subway today you know in every episode
the characters were real characters and
that and I think like what a what a
brand like protecting that brand what it
used to be isn't what it is today
because now people are more willing to
make
themselves a little and they realized
that the audience you know sort of
catches you know is along with the joke
and I feel like a brand that's a that's
able to do that that is able to roll
with the punches make fun of itself
shows that it's modern shows that you
know it it makes people attracted to it
and I think you know you've got to
partner with somebody who's willing to
not in a not interfere with the creative
process but at the same time trust you
to not embarrass their brand and so I
would say you you would target
like-minded brand or whatever you want
to do and then when you get in there I'm
not the kind of person that says you
know wait till I show you the numbers or
whatever I think you've got to sit down
and at the end of the day if a person
wants to do business with you or was to
be in business with you it's got to be
more of what do you agree you know how
do you get along do you agree with this
person do you have similar philosophies
and are you is your roadmap leading
toward the same destination and I think
if you sit down with with a brand and
you talk to about what your ideas are
what your vision is have as much to show
them as possible I mean if you can do
storyboards if you can do you know a
comic book if you can do you know a
little short presentation of you know a
trailer or something you can start to
show them what your vision is and what
you will do if they entrust you with
with their money and with their brand
then do a deal and go into business and
and hopefully it will work out because
you know the brand itself can provide a
tremendous amount of marketing if
they're behind it they can provide that
sort of missing element that US indie
producers don't have you know
you